Myron one of the hosts was saying it is
cheating if a girl has an Instagram when
she's in a relationship
um but don't worry the men the men can
have an Instagram though that's not
cheating and okay so the reason being is
because when you have social media on
some level you're looking for attention
right on some level you're looking for
attention from someone otherwise you
wouldn't post yes no I have to I have to
agree with that no I think you
I love taking pictures I do I love being
creative but at the end of the day if
you have a crush on someone
you post that one story for them to view
it oh we've all done that yeah you dress
up kill you do your little
we can't we can't yeah we don't well you
post that one like pretty picture for
him to be like
well my ex is gonna have he does have
Instagram though but I blocked him for
example and I do love to take pictures
but I don't do in order to I don't know
trigger him or tease him yeah or like to
get attention I do love photos I do love
myself I actually this Probably sounds a
little bit
ego or narcissist I spent way more time
looking at my pictures than are actually
other people
I actually I'm like I don't give a [ __ ]
who pays attention to me yeah I actually
just like but then why then why I like
to see my profile like looking good you
know and that's it then but then why
post it at all and you can just keep
them in your camera roll yeah exactly
but I just like feel a bit more like I
can show to my friends for example my
Instagram is from it's private yeah so I
only accept people that I want to they I
mean to be you know be there yeah and
see right they want to share even though
it's just people I met once I feel okay
it's a good vibe it's a you know I will
keep it but it's not in order to get
attention I feel like
it's getting attention from people you
know might be a smaller group yeah it
can be it can be a very like you said a
small amount of group but at the end of
the day if it was just for your eyes
only yeah
yeah I think that's what she's trying to
say about like likes you know no that's
something else though
it's just it's just it has levels to it
yeah different level of attention yeah
yeah that's right yes so the question I
have for you guys
um is do you think having an Instagram
is cheating to start no no no it gives
you the opportunity to okay but
everything gives you the opportunity to
cheat walk in taking the tube gives you
an opportunity to cheat not really not
really I feel like or not I don't feel
like I think I think Instagram
has two has two nowadays has like two
main purposes business or dating facts
the reality is so if if your girl how
many people have tried to slide in your
DMs
how many of you guys have swiped up on a
story you know I left the fire Emoji or
the heart or something I mean just like
there's or it's either you're promoting
your business or at some stage someone
is going to move to you or you're going
to move to someone else so I feel like
yeah Instagram is one one of those two
things so it it offers you the
opportunity it's kind of it's kind of
like you're selling yourself like it's
like your online portfolio like your
representation of yourself like so
you're showing your good parts like
you're showing yourself looking your
best for other people
yeah no for for attention for other
people to view it so no but we were
talking about the other day where like
Instagram and everything like that it's
actually a social currency now like even
when you go out and stuff the more
followers you have the more like you can
do the easier you should get into things
that element of it the business element
but as a girl if your Instagram's open
and it's not private
like you want the attention if you're
not doing if you're not if you're not
trying to like sell something towards a
business or like do something I feel
like it's for attention
a little bit I think it's a great way to
have an Instagram even if it's open or
private I mean when it's open of course
I think you have way more possibilities
you know to create a business to share
and to create more following definitely
uh some I don't think he's like the main
reason is like to like to create an
Instagram is to cheat sorry to cheat not
[ __ ]
but yeah I mean
um I think you can [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm Portuguese guys don't judge me
um [ __ ] cheat thank you cheat uh you can
cheat anywhere you know I mean there was
cheating before Instagram before social
media before internet I I think even my
parents I don't know if they cheat but
you know even that happened before but
without internet without you know uh
smartphones it was like a Nokia the
Snake Game you know that's it but I
think what he was trying to say I agree
with you that's what I said as well but
I think it gives you an outlet to do it
easier yeah we have I think all of us
have experienced someone being a
relationship posting it and then they
swipe up on your story yeah you're like
what
I think it just gives you an interesting
Stat one in three Affairs that cause a
divorce are from social media exactly
yeah
yeah one in three yeah there we go so I
feel like social media has made it
harder for relationships to work because
your Azure as a guy you're seeing all
these beautiful girls on your timeline
constantly you're gonna be tempted
you're like oh there's more beautiful
girls out there you're seeing all these
girls so it's like it's tempting you and
you're seeing that every day constantly
constantly you're like oh
oh yeah I think it works both ways as
well though because as a guy like back
in the day you would just obviously
before social media if you were just
competing with the guys that went to
your school or the guys in your area and
now you're competing with people from
America that have Yachts
planes like and you're just here like
I'm making enough but like bro I ain't
got no yacht do you know what no you go
you go first the amount of goals I know
so like the aren't that aren't them that
greatest looking in the world like just
normal yeah that have much
a bunch of Blue Tick guy I'm talking I'm
not gonna bait out teams but a lot of
fun I've gone through the requests
I request I have a question is it
because she while she looks average in
real life on her Instagram it's so
edited she looks above average
yeah Instagram's online
she reveals
she's like a good body catfish catfish
what she's not wearing a lot yeah yeah
so it's kind of screaming like easy
there's a thin line as well between that
subject I think some people they feel
like they think like some women
too much it's because they want they are
weak and they are insecure and they are
trying to you know call some attention
but I don't think so like some people
maybe some other people not I think it's
all about who you are in the end of the
day because sometimes I met a few people
they look so wow on Instagram and then
you meet them and they are very humble
they are very confident like confident
you know and they are not at all what
you think yeah but I I think that
if you're posting your body on Instagram
it's a hundred percent for attention
like there is nothing else that it is
for yep you want you want validation for
your body I'm not I'm not above it I
think I
understand where you're coming from and
half of it is 100 that right but I think
also when you're like
um happy with something or proud of it
like proud of the work of you done like
the progress you made yeah you do but
absolutely for people to see it or else
it would have been staying in your
camera roll yeah I agree yeah but I
think also to show that you're like
proud of it so other question when on
social media what do you guys consider
cheating I'm going to give you a couple
examples
this is fun so guys liking Instagram
models bikini pictures
it's not cheating but it's like why was
that necessary
cheating but it's just kind of moist why
why are you doing it but if you saw like
a male would you no because I was like
why would I do it but I understand like
it's not cheating
out and it's like it's okay for the guys
out there that do that like why yeah
exactly she doesn't see exactly yeah on
the guys part it's just thirsty and it's
it's a bit moist yeah yeah it's a bit
worse yeah there's no point in doing
that just look let's go that's it yeah
yeah I think we all have eyes and we
appreciate beautiful things it's human
so if I see a guy that is pretty and he
looks good and he looks hot even on the
street I mean I'm not gonna be like like
on him if if I see it on Instagram why
not you know like even if you're in a
relationship yeah I feel like at least I
can see if my partner is confident and
if you trust me because there's a
trouble on that that I will say okay my
partner doesn't trust me and my partner
is insecure and I'm I'm not up to that
you know I think everyone has
insecurities but you should not
um I heard you say Miro those
insecurities with others wait could you
say that again so what makes them
insecure
like me liking someone who's who are not
not liking how would you say me thinking
that someone is beautiful it's okay to
see right she's beautiful right she's
beautiful yeah but that's something else
though that's something completely else
that's just appreciating that people are
like yeah but I think there's a
difference between looking at someone
and interaction with it I think because
it's sending them a message exactly it's
the message you're sending no no but I
like like I think
yeah it's like baby steps you know what
I mean like it starts it starts for him
to like because most of the time
nowadays I feel like especially girls on
Instagram their way of shooting their
shot is they just like one or two of
your photos boys as well men as well
some guys will follow the girl if you're
like if you're like if you're about that
life you just like a few and just see
what happens in it but here's the thing
because usually nine times out of ten
the man is pursuing the like if if a guy
likes a girl's photo she's most the time
she's not gonna then jump in his DMS
most of the time you might like it back
and wait for them to do it if the girl
likes the guy's picture that's that's an
invitation that's yeah that's a Golden
Ticket slide in please yeah yeah so yeah
so the guys so girls yeah they'll like
two or three photos and that's when you
know that's when you slide in yeah
that's when you know that's when you
know that's like this especially if
you've just post a photo and you they've
just liked it that's nothing but if you
haven't posted anything in a couple
weeks they've gone on your page they've
gone through your photos like it might
not even be the most recent three it
might be they've scored through lacked
couple photos what if what if they
because that's the new thing like liking
Instagram stories do you guys think
that's also no invitation dislike yeah
Instagram story if you like Instagram
story that's demon times
you're not a good you know a good thing
about that as well no one can see the
lights
because sometimes you might click on
them you might click on a photo you
might look through the lights see who
are who's liked it as one of my boys
liked it but stories you can't do that
to us so yeah
so everything so what okay so what about
swiping up on someone's story yeah is
that cheating is that okay okay
is that cheating but you know the person
if you know but as in as in does he
swipe up and he's like oh have a good
workout or is it okay let's say let's
say you you have an acquaintance that
both of both of you know okay the guy
you and the guy right and he swipes up
on our stories how do you know if it
like is it ever friendly no is it always
it is flirty what about guys what do you
think
can you we're gonna repeat that okay so
say say
um
okay say it say me and you were dating
right okay and you and I'm your Mutual
yeah we're the mutual friend you always
are swiping up on her story but like we
both are on the clock right
is it ever friendly
if I'm always doing it there's there's
an under there's probably an underlying
exactly yeah like I said if he's just
like oh do you know when or was the
movie good was this good like what
that's that's fine or like reacting all
the time